you know there was a interesting moment
I didn't even
um
listen to the wars exchanged but because
I had the great Fortune of sitting next
to hacho crazy there was this uh
fascinating moment before the match and
I can't believe Gordon is sufficiently
relaxed to do this but he walked up to
uh haja Gracie and had a discussion what
do you think you faced Hunter Gohan
before what are your suggestions and
they've talked to back and forth they
brainstormed ideas like minutes before
the match and it was just a beautiful
moment of like I don't know like like
Tiger Woods and Michael Jordan talking
to each other something like that I mean
I I wonder how much brainstorming there
really was or and how much was it just
kind of um
ins like spiritual inspiration or
something like that yeah the I think
it's more spiritual inspiration he looks
up to algerism as a uh uh Hodges a very
close friend a mentor of mine so I
always tell my athletes look to harder
as your example this is a guy who
always fought for the Finish he tried to
express the the highest ideal of Jiu
Jitsu which is control leading to
submission and every match he was ever
in he even lost matches
on tactics against people that he could
easily have defeated if he adopted a
different tactic but he always insisted
on Victory by submission it defined his
career made of who who he was and I
always try to have my athletes emulate
him